DEVELOPMENTS WE
IGHT
IN THE WAR IN UKRA UKRAINIANBE
ANPORTANT TOWNE EA, VLADIMIR P
CELEBRATORY CONCER RED
SQ
THAT RUSSIA WOFOUR
REGIIN UNCE SAMEN
DONETSK WHERINIANS
TO BE CI
TROOPS, ENCIRCNG RUSSIAN
TROOPS.
SO THIS WAS  BE
PUTIN'S WORDS WERET CONFRONTATI
CONSPIRATORIAL.
SEEMED TO BE ECTING, CHARGING
U.S. WITH BEING DESPOT
WHO INFRINGE O
AND BRK INTERNATIONA
TO INCLUDE LANDS HIS ES
NEVERTLEDAY HE
IT, QUOTE, OUR
>> WANE KYIV
THS AND THR EST TOEAR AND
PEOPLE IN THOSE
FOUR REGIONS ARE BECOMING OUCIT.
AT THEIR USE AND ONCE AG
BLAMING THE UNITED
>> Translator: THE COUNT WEDLEN
A
>> IN RESPONSE PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAIN'SIGN
STRUGGL
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENW A, QUO,
FARCE.
I'M JOINEDER OUR SENIOR
TETTY REPORTED FR ZONERAE M MOSD
CNN NATIONAL SECURITY ANALYST
STEVLL OPERATIONALWAYSU IN PERNM
IT IS FIERY ANCO NDREDS OF THNDH
THE DIRECTION THATE'
HOW DOOUHI THE RUSSIAN
O A THINK'RE RIGHT. MSI
F PATRIOTIT WE
R TI
IN RE
CT BETWEEN THAD
ATN
BATTLEFIELD, FIRST OF ALL, I
MEAN THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I
CAN THINK OFT A COS ERRITORY IT
BEY THE SI
UKRA.
AASSIVE
ATDEANS FEELTHINK, WH E
NOW ABOUT WHAT RUSSIA CALLS THE
BECAUSE AS WTARYRA
CELEBRATIONS AEIN
CAUNDREDS
THOUSAOFENG
EA TO ESCAPE
DRAFT.
THEY KNOW THEY NEE OUT
AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN OTHERWIS
BLOODBATH.
>> JUSTOTHAT, DO
YOU VEOM TOD
MOBILIZATION FROM A FEWES IRED?
TELY BKF
SEEING DATH THIS NOW, OF
WHCTORY IS AIMED ADIE GOT
N TRADITIONAL
THSTMEG TO BE OME, AND HAL PRON
T YARNO RUSSIANS,
YOU KNOWFOR THEABLE
>> STEVEALET ME FOLLOW UP
ON TT  YOU Y S
JOHN IAST LLRE PEOPLE ARE ALREA.
KNOWOR THOSE HIT'S WIN
PARTS OF THE RUSSIANST
ABOUT THAT.
AND MOST OOSE POTIE KNOW PARTS D
AND THE BIG SHOW
PERSON.
'RVEHOSE
THINGSINGS PLAY BETTER IN THRUS
GETTING ACCESS TO RNET
AND HAVE TO RELY MORE ON RUSSI
MEDIA.
BUT ALSO KNOWS TT IS NOT
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.>> DO YOU
CONFLICT WITSTS
INEVITABLE, ST HS E CAREFUL BY
AT IT
WE MEAN OF CONFLICT WITH THE .DH
THT SAYING
TES USED THEM, O
THAT'S A PRECEDENT.
HIM BECAUSE WE GET IWE ABOUTECA
WES T E'UC
BUT HE AUSSIAN
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING SOME SORT
NUCLEARFR
THE WEST,
NUCLEARY LONG, I DON THIHAT TOF.
GOLYEILED
VEALLY OR AT LEASTR SCIR
PUTIN, WHAOUHIING AT THERE THE E
G THE STAKES. GOT MUCSE T ON APS
CLE HIS TI ARMY HAS, YOUNOFAILE
MI OBJECTIS.EY'VE BEEN BRIINACBR
THIS KD OF
TO SCARE
UKRAINE INTO BACKINGOW>>RETO SE
COUNTER OFFES NICK PATEN WALSH
TEAM RECENTLY VISITED A NEWLTED.
WH
S ONE OFE
PEOPLE LEFT CKSHALT MAKE>> TranS
WHEN THE RUSSIANREI WAS IN TOO
TO HOLD THE STEEDOOR SHUT, BUT
A SOLDIER PULLED AT THE DOOR SO
HEORR, SHOT HIS
ME.ISSED
>>IGHT, HERE IS S
WALSH IN EASTERN
UKRAINE.
T IS THIS SO-CALLED
ANNEXATION MEAN TO
UKRAINIANS?
>> Reporter: WELL, NOTHING
HONEST. COURS Y
RUSSIA ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY
OCCU HAS DECLARE
N YOU DO IN THEORY
HAVE A NNMENT
EYES.M  A
PLACE WHICF THIS MORNING SSIA S
THINKS IS PART
UAND THAT BRINGTHINK,
HOW AT TIMESL WHAT
HEARD
YES, THERE WAS STRONG MESSAGING
ITME ABOUT TRYINT MISTAKES AND .
AND WHAT YOU'RE CERTAINLY SEEIN
THE AND THANCE  DIREC
S UKRAINRWARD.
Y LOOK LIKELY ORSAS  TROOPF IT..
THOS CLD SURRENDER O
OUT, AND HAVE KNOCK OFECT
RUSSIAN POSITIONS IN THE AREA
THE ISSUE HERE IS THE RHETORIC
ON THEEFIELD HERE,G TOE SOMETHI
PUTIN IS
STRUGGLING MASSIVELY TIDGE
GAP BETWEEN HIS
IT FELL TO E NES, JOH
THE SSIANS.
HA HF TEGIC INIA
WHATOUPOR WHAT'S
NEXT?
>> Reporter: WELL, IF YOU LOOK
T UKRAINIAN STRATEGY
CERTNLY WHEN THE AREAS AROUND
V FELL, THCUS OF
WAS TOWN CALLED
IZIUM WHICH WAY TH
HUBTEGICALLY
IMANT TO RUSSIA BE
USED THAT TOPLY ITS OTHE
AND REMARKABLY,
EVERYTHING FELL  WON
AND THERE ARE THOUGHTSBLY
LEMAN FILLS A SIMILANCTION
IN THE DONETSKANSK
AR RUSSIHAS HAD
OBLYPROBABLY HAVE MORE
NS IN PLACE, BUT WE HAVE
NABLE TO WORK OUT  W IA PLACE
IT DIDN'T THINK LD LOSE.PEAPA O
ATE DONE?FALLING W
THEY'VE GONE AROUNHER THAN DOINA
THEY'VUTHE I FRONTAL WITH L LIVS
SUPPLY BY GOINHE BACK
OF IT.THAT'S WHAT WE'RSEEING AT
ONE FROM THERE IS THE TOWNS
ITH